welcome everybody to the data science hangout
um welcome back to all the familiar faces
uh i think most people who are on now have
joined before but if this is your first one
this is an open space for current and aspiring
data science leaders to just connect and
learn from each other so we don't have an agenda
for the the calls or focuses on questions that are
most important to you all so there's three ways
that you can ask questions you could jump in live
put questions in the zoom chat or we also have
a slido so you can ask anonymous questions too
and just want to point out that this session
will be recorded and shared up to youtube as well
but i'm so excited to be joined by my co-host
for today paul ditterline director of data
science at heaven hill brands and paul i think
if it's okay with you just turn it over to you
to maybe have you introduce yourself and share
a bit about your team and the work that you do
yeah sure so hey everybody um like rachel said my
name is paul and i'm the director of data science
at heaven hill we make um some of the best
spirits in the world so you've probably heard
of things like evan williams and elijah craig
and some other cool products like hypnotic
we do a we make a lot of cool products at
heaven hill from a data science perspective
um it's really cool because we are a really
work consumer package goods company and we have
production facilities and we have things like
shipping and then we also have things like um
marketing and sales and infrastructure to support
the end-to-end production and sales of um of our
products so there's a lot of cool opportunity
there for data science in every aspect of that
process and so i lead a team called data services
under the leadership of a relatively new cio
that's really trying to tackle this head-on and
build a data science foundation really from the
foundation level which includes how our erp system
and data systems are organized and communicate all
the way up through how we can pull analytics out
of those systems and derive business value that we
can easily communicate to the business so that's i
think that's kind of a nutshell what my team does
awesome and as we're waiting for questions to come
in from the from the audience i think it'd be cool
to to hear from you what's something that you're
really excited about in data science right now
yeah so i've kind of got a few answers for
that you know that's a really broad question
to me if i think about it locally in my current
work i'm really excited about the foundational
work we're doing from an iet level to make it
easier to do data science right like what how
do we get all these disparate systems to more
easily talk to each other and provide the raw
material of data to our analysts so that we can
we can spend less time munging and more time you
know providing insight which i know is like the
bane of every single data scientist uh probably
that exist today um a little bit if i step back
a second from that um i'm excited about tools
like gpt3 and how they might change the type
of products that we can make i've been on the
waiting list for like i think it was like a year
and i recently got access so i've been really
excited about thinking about how i can use um
you know large neural networks like that in my
own work and what sort of value i can use with
this i would say relatively new uh tool that you
know i've never had access to before aside from
things that i could train and then i i regularly
just sort of geek out on upcoming packages and
functionality especially within the rstudio set of
products so there's a really cool resource called
our weekly that i checked kind of religiously
usually at the end of reading that
i've got like 30 open tabs that are
recent papers that people have published
or upcoming packages or changes to packages
or blog posts about how to use some packages i'm
interested in like most recently i've gotten into
using blastula connected our markdown to try
to move away from like go-to dashboards to more
automated exception-based reporting that informs
whenever something happens so instead of having to
go to dig for something people sort of get that
hand delivered to them and using tools like the
connect api package which is relatively new has
been really cool to build those types of things
awesome sorry a little over the place there no
that that's great um i see there's a question
in the slido that speaks to what you you mentioned
earlier since data services is under the cio is it
relatively easy for your team to get what you need
from it yeah this was a really big learning for me
actually my previous employer i spent seven years
at brown foreman um starting off in r d as an
analyst and at the end of my career there i i was
helping implement the global advanced analytics
function and one problem that i noticed there was
traditional i.t was sort of this thing and then
data science was like this this other thing and
sometimes those two things collided in ways that
weren't the best in terms of agility in terms
of like implementing the data science solution
so one of the things i pushed for at
heaven hill uh when we got the new cio was
trying to put all those things into one vertical
and and the answer is yes like having the folks
that sort of build those data platforms uh build
those pipelines with the analytics and the data
science needs in mind has been incredibly
helpful yeah and i i and from my experience
i would highly recommend some sort of integration
along those lines from a business perspective
cool and i know you just so you just mentioned
about working at brown foreman as well so i think
it might be helpful for the audience or some of
the aspiring data science leaders to understand um
like where you started there at brown foreman
and then also how you got into leadership
as well and and what your journey looks
like yeah um you know i i think that using
one of the things that that i like about r um
and RStudio is really it's the packages and
the functionality but it's also the community
and the and the openness and how do i use this
and years ago like what a decade ago
now or when i was starting off there
as as just an analyst a new person
who really wanted to make an impact
i was able to do a lot more than i think i could
have because of the tools that existed in the r
community so instead of doing like one-off
analysis and providing an answer i was able to say
learn shiny and spin up an application that solved
that problem not just once but over time and i was
able to use those free open source tools to to
come to my leadership at the time and say hey if
we had x we could solve problems this way and over
years of building that i was able to sort of push
push that strategy and push the thinking into
that direction so really it was just um using
the tools that were available to show a vision
with tangible assets that people could understand
and then leading that into sort of what the vision
for data science could be in the future and that's
what kind of got me from doing it at the ground
level to helping lead the implementation of that
so but without those tools i think it would have
been really hard to try to do something like that
and i know i know that's something that a
lot of people are probably going through now
like from being a data analyst and trying to like
can i sell the idea of data science internally as
well so i'm sure there'll be some follow-up
questions there um but bruno i see you asked
a question in the chat and i'd love to hand
the mic over to you if you want to ask it live
sure thanks for doing this paul uh retail is
pretty interesting how do you tackle the whole
data the data along the supply chain up to
the retail store do you get like very fine
data details or can you can you uh i don't know
put process in place to gather more information
so it's a little interesting with
with alcohol sales in america
we have what's called a a three-tiered system
where we're not allowed to sell directly to the
store that sells it to you this is a prohibition
um legal effect that's been in place since then so
we essentially have to sell two distributors who
then sell to individual stores so that does create
you know some difficulty in sort of getting that
data however we do have really good partnerships
with those distributors and we are able to get
um at the store daily not really transaction
level what's what's being shipped from them into
the stores so at it's kind of a headache because
you have to deal with like what we're shipping to
this third party and then what they're shipping to
a consumer right so it's like two different sets
of metrics but we are kind of lucky that we have
we can get to that store level data but we have a
lot of um creative assets in play to try to try to
get us that information as as quickly and as at
the lowest level possible it's not always easy
chris i see you asked a question as well
around how much of what the what work is
being done is through cloud services chris
do you want to add any other contacts there
uh yeah um again like everyone says thanks
paul for doing this always appreciate having
these guest data scientists coming in to do
this um so i i work i work with air force um
mainly uh special operation command stuff and
all that and one of the challenges that we have
within our data science community is you know the
traditional things like you talked about before
where you have your your siloed information and
stuff like that and now they're talking about um
you know the possibility of working in uh
cloud environments and that and i just wanted
to get your take as to whether or not you and
your team are doing more of your analytics uh
on a cloud basis compared to the normal data
styles that you see in a lot of companies
yeah so from a from a data perspective from that
end we're definitely mostly on-prem uh we're
in the middle of a strategy again i mentioned we
got a new ceo and uh i'm sorry a new cio in uh in
january and he's implemented a strategy that does
include sort of a cloud-based future and we're in
the process of moving it from a data perspective
from an analytics perspective we're in the process
of moving to that traditional emailing each other
excel files analytics to a more um i kind of think
of it as two different pathways i want a pathway
for someone who writes code and r or python or
whatever i need them to be successful i need them
to connect to data sources create products easily
post them to some web-based outcome one source
of truth you know get backed up all of that but
then i need a more what i might call an analyst
professional someone who needs a more modern
tool from excel needs to provide that web-based
experience and isn't going to learn how to code
so you know that's like maybe a tableau or a power
bi right so we're transitioning um into setting up
the uh the infrastructure we need to support
both of those we've already got RStudio team
implemented uh on-prem for the data science
side and that's working well for us and we're
probably moving to power bi for the um for
the analyst side because we're we're also a
microsoft company that's just kind of you know
um who we use for our tech solution so um yeah
so i guess to succinctly answer that nearly all
on-prem now but with a with a current um strategy
that's in progress to move to the cloud in the
next let's say five years okay thank you yeah
thanks paul there are a few anonymous questions
coming in on slido too and and one is what is
something that is impacted by data science
in your industry that you might not expect
so one one thing that comes to mind um is barrel
yield so if you some people might not know much
about about spirits right i'm a little biased
because i live in kentucky and here everybody
knows about bourbon because it's the famous
saying that there are more you know barrels of
bourbon than there are kentuckians um well when
you make when you make a whiskey or bourbon you
make a distillate and you put it in a barrel and
if you've never seen one of these barrels they're
they're really big they hold about 55 gallons of
liquid and then they go into a warehouse and when
they're full they weigh about 500 pounds and they
sit in a warehouse for um you know four to 12 to
even longer years and of course due to evaporation
and soakage and maybe issues with barrels
you're going to have some amount of liquid left in
that barrel whenever you go to dump it and as you
might imagine especially if you're in finance the
you know a couple percent changes in that amount
that's a big deal i mean that's product that you
thought you would have that you don't have so
using some cool data science methods to get data
from places that i wouldn't have really expected
to feed that into models that can help predict
what yields are going to be was something i didn't
think would work but that did and and that's a
really cool thing that we use in our business
that's so cool and what's your favorite bourbon
oh man um i've always liked um elijah craig since
before i came to heaven hill elijah craig rye got
whiskey advocates number seven last year they do
like a blind test every year and ranked them all
but our larceny our barrel proof larceny which is
a weeded bourbon got number one actually so that's
been pretty popular but i'm an elijah craig fan
going back to uh packages there's a another
anonymous question what packages do you use most
for modeling and machine learning is it primary
tidy models and related or do you also use python
why yeah so i i like tidy models i like the
framework there um i actually i i came up in
base r so if i'm doing like a logistic regression
or a linear model i mean i got to be honest
oftentimes i'll bang it out quickly and based our
before i move on to like a tidy model framework
um for like machine learning and deep learning
um i use the keras and tensorflow packages um
that's what we have in production now for
the model for the models that we're using
and stepping out a bit from machine learning
the tidy verse is always like the first thing
that i call pretty much everything that i'm
doing um i i live in our markdown i think that
unless you're doing something that's very
very small and one-off you should almost
always start your work at our markdown because the
point of the work you're doing is probably going
to be to communicate something and you're going to
end up doing double work you're going to probably
write a script and then maybe you would open
god forbid word or something like that to like
make a report while you're writing your
code but if you come with that in mind
you can open our markdown start it off as a report
do your analytical work organize it and at the end
of the day you've pushed a button you have a
beautiful html web page with a floating table
of contents code chunks that fold in and out you
can also use python or r or sql or d3 or other
languages within those chunks and then if you
have team you can push button to host that to
team shoot someone url and now you have a one
source of truth hosted report that anyone can
go to that you can control access to and you did
all that in one markdown script so our markdown
is just completely invaluable for the work that
i do we're actually looking at trying to take
some of our etl work directly into a markdown
base like a notebook-based format just because
the documentation and the scheduling and all that
kind of comes along for the ride whenever you
whenever you do that work um i like shiny a lot
but i'm also a big fan of flex dashboard because
it's really lightweight it's really fast uh you
can write your you can write your like reactive
code right there instead of kind of having code
in the server and then referring to that code in
the ui if it's something small um something very
quick i mean i i can go from nothing to a hosted
flex dashboard with reactives in like an hour
and a half and so if i need something very fast
i will use that the other really cool thing about
flex dashboard is if you're not using reactivity
you can actually and you don't have a way to host
applications to sort of show the value of what
you're doing you can email the resulting knitted
html the flex dashboard to someone and when they
open it it opens like a beautiful web page that's
interactive for them and that's a really cool way
to share content if you don't yet have the ability
to to publish and host stuff and i actually took
advantage of that at brown for foreman to try
to show people uh what you can do with our tools
um if i think of little things like luberdate
is like man i'm always using the day for dates
because i hate dealing with dates so much um
so yeah those are those are the those are the
main ones that come to mind there's like a
thousand more i'm sure that's just what's in
my brain right now thank you i see in the chat
there's a lot of conversation going on around
our markdown and shannon i think you asked a great
question earlier if um you want to jump in as well
yeah i was just curious i mean you said
you live in our markdown so as a director
are you writing code daily um i'm not
writing code daily i'm writing code um
weekly and that's that's one of the uh that's one
of the issues uh most people probably have it um i
definitely have it personally is as you move into
more managerial or leadership roles you know your
value tends to be derived from from just that from
your leadership right not so much from the code uh
i i don't want to lose that capability so
um i do try to dive in and help on projects
uh submit pull requests do that sort of thing and
i i have a pretty strong opinion about how to do
data science so i don't want to be like a micro
manager type of person but you know if someone's
doing a bunch of filtering and they're not using
d player i'm probably going to make a comment on
so this is stuff like that yeah frank it looks
like you and paul are in the same library with
your backgrounds oh yeah funny enough i was
just trying to figure out what common books
we have on our bookshelf he's actually here
next to me we just have two computers by myself
yeah um just scrolling through um to see some
of the questions that were asked in the chat if
the rstudio team would be able to help me just
organize a little bit but um steve i see that you
commented a bit on using our markdown as well we'd
love to kind of open it up to the audience as well
if you have things to share about the way you use
our markdown 2. tony uh just asked the question
around internal packages paul and and ask
how many internal packages do you host
right so i only have one internal package
currently um i mean i i see a world where
there's a handful of those um for our use case
i think i think i think that'd be about it
although to be fair um i know that movement
toward like package-based development especially
with things like golem is you know um it's pretty
huge right now and i haven't dug into it enough
but i we have found it helpful just to create
helper packages for commonly used functions for
sort of data munching or modeling that we
tend to do on a regular basis i see ian
asked a question earlier as well and said he's
in a noisy office so i'll read the question
but do any of your analytics and data science rely
on a vip a third-party vendor for the beverage
industry for your distributor data said the reason
i ask is i'd like to hear your insights on taking
and consuming data from third-party vendors that
you can't get an api into so yeah yes so so we you
know in the earlier question about sort of data at
that distributor and the retail level you know i i
made a joke about some creative solutions and you
do kind of have these vendors that have um i'm not
sure what the right phrase is um historic methods
of getting data to you and oftentimes there's not
a lot you can do about that so we just try
to automate that in the um in the best way
possible that fits our infrastructure and
doesn't require a lot of human interaction
to to bring that data into our environment i
think that's all i can say about about that
but we do work with vip data yeah
i know that's something that we talked about with
the team at the city of reykjavik as well and
understanding their story that i would have never
thought about um like making sure that certain
like tools that you purchase or other vendors
allow you to get access to the data or like
that that's part of your contract and it's
something i wouldn't have considered before
i i see zach you asked um i was curious
i guess it's because of paul and frank's
backgrounds but if you have all-time
favorite books yeah i i guess like um
with a library like that i figure you probably
have like way too many but i'm jealous of the
the book of walls so would definitely be
curious if you guys have any favorites
we got paul you need to go first okay well
it's hard if i think like all-time favorites
like um all-time favorites like uh meditations by
marcus aurelius is probably i don't know maybe my
favorite book of all time i think there's reading
that book and thinking about the problems that
this um guy was dealing with you know hundreds
of years before i was born and how it how it
intervenes into the life that i live today
has just always fascinated me and i'm a fan of
stoicism in general i really like ryan holiday's
recent books um on uh the obstacle is the way an
ego is the enemy i think those are really really
good books um sort of from a completely different
perspective i really love carlo rivelli's
recent books on business on on physics in
general his uh five brief lessons and physics
is fantastic and you can read that in like 20
minutes and his most recent book called helgoland
hegoland is about um it's like a succinct summary
of like why we think quantum mechanics is true
so those are the ones that sort of come to mind
i definitely lean toward uh nonfiction myself and
i do i do have a signed copy of r for data science
somewhere here that uh that had the wickham sign
which i like a lot sometimes i just you know
like to produce through that but that's what i've
got i definitely lean towards non-fiction i um
uh like leadership books and continuous
improvements so i love jim collins
series of books i think i could read those
multiple times um and then the more data
science book that i read sort of recently was
business data science by matt taddy which i
thought he does a fantastic job of going pretty
deep into and it's all all the examples are in r
he does a fantastic job bridging between this
is what your output looks like and this is what
it means in your statistics class and this is
how you would use it if you were working with
a stakeholder right so he does an awesome job
balancing so i'm gonna write it in the in the um
in the chat but i highly recommend it to everyone
on here you just mentioned like a business focus
book and it reminded me that um my leadership team
and i just read this together prediction machines
and um you know as a data scientist you're not
going to really learn a lot about what ai can do
but what this really was good at was framing like
what is ai and that's why it's called prediction
machines because it's like the way to talk about
stakeholders is what these things do is make
predictions make really accurate predictions
depending on um what it is that you're doing
and if you think about that if you think about it
that way now you can think okay what do i have in
my business that could benefit from having really
accurate predictions made what if predictions are
cheap based on you know basic economics what
does that mean for future predictions and this
was a really good way to talk about what we could
do with data science with my executive team so
i'd recommend an exercise like that it was helpful
for us i think um and you could start like a book
club for the community i think that would be
super super fun that would be cool yeah i just
looked at that book paul and you can i just want
to let everyone know you can buy it on target.com
like if we go anywhere my kids are like we're
going to target them yep that's where we're going
tatiana asked a great question in the chat too
um could i pass the mic over to you to have you
asked that sure uh but my first question is
what was it predictive modeling the book the
book oh this book is called uh prediction
machines that's the cover yep all right so
um and that's by um it's got three it's got
three authors yeah that i'm going that i will
just completely butcher if i try to say them so
i'll let you google for you i feel like so yeah
um okay so as from as far as my question uh and
uh eli is also waiting on answer is basically no
pressure basically uh with your plans to implement
analytics and power bi across the organization uh
one of the bigger challenges is to set i guess
adequate adoption rates and then develop a
strategy around it and i'm not i don't want to ask
for the strategy because it's probably ongoing but
what are your thoughts on how to are there any
mental models that you adopt or uh what are the
main thoughts around uh some pitfalls or uh some
small wins that you can make at the beginning like
anything you can share on that so are you asking
about really how to be successful with like the
implementation of something like power bi is that
what you're asking yeah well uh the analytics in
general right how do you uh well depending on
your goals because i joined a bit later but
if your goal is make the organization data
driven or if your goal is increase power bi
use depending on your adoption targets um right
so so i guess our goal so if i back up and look
um i think you need to have an integrated
strategy from the top down i think that's
very important that's one of the things that our
company has been working on um over the you know
over the past uh year especially since we've got
the new it organization in place and one of those
one of those um strategic initiatives is
make database decisions well then you have
to understand like what does that mean like what
does it mean to make database decisions well the
way that we think about that is it needs to be
um very easy to to get that and to use it if
it's hard to do you're not going to do it and it
has to come from a source of truth that everyone
could understand and it has to be um it can't be
locked down to a specific platform so that's why
you might have heard me talk earlier
about web-based web-based web-based
you know i don't want someone to have to
have a certain program on their computer
everything has a web browser right so if you're on
your phone in the middle of the store i want you
to be able to pull up something that someone
on my team made and get an answer from it so
that sort of philosophy that connects to like the
executive kpi of database decisions is what drives
the implementation of something like power bi or
of like RStudio team so when we're making tools
it's not about making some cool thing that the
data scientist thinks is cool which you know
i like to do that too it's really about making
sure you're connected to the people who need to
be making database decisions and making sure that
that's what you're doing because you don't have
their job you don't live their world and they
know more about what they need than you do so
that sort of philosophy comes all the way through
really how we're implementing the tools to get
to the result that we want right we don't want a
bunch of people just making a bunch of cool things
that doesn't really go anywhere we want strategic
sort of surgical um collaborative kpi based tools
being made between analysts and the business
that drive the goal of database decision making
all right so it sounds like um it's
mostly sticking to the top-down
rate strategy making sure that
you develop the appropriate kpis
before you roll out the strategy and then
make it accessible and avoid data silos
absolutely i feel like i should add like what
i said might sound like it's a little bit um
i want to do that but i also don't want to be uh
restrictive like if someone has a great idea for
some cool thing that no one's asked for that's
awesome like let's like we'll do that and we'll
and we'll pitch it and we'll see if it connects
so i i don't want to give the impression that
i'm like you can only work on the things that meet
these like we want to have strategy but we want to
be agile as well so i think there's room for both
of those things how do you prioritize those kpis
then or decide like what the team's working
on first so we've uh we've been coming from
what you might call a more traditional i.t setup
where you know folks get tickets and folks solve
that problem and then they think um that you
know they've they've done 10 tickets today and
that's and then that's good and it is good but
really sometimes you've got to step back and say
why am i getting that ticket what what's the
real need um you know our cio allen has this
thing where he says you really gotta ask why
five times right like you've got to get to that
base level of what is happening what is the real
business need and the other thing is you know what
what people what people want what they think they
want and what they really need are usually three
completely different things right so we we've
tried to move into this organizational structure
where there are people whose real really job
it is to be business liaisons with different
folks around the business so that we can make
sure it's not just doing tickets it's not just um
solving immediate technical needs it's really
making sure oh someone asked me for a report
and i give them the report you know the old way
of thinking is you know that's great i'm done
but now someone asked me for a report well why do
you want that oh it's because i'm trying to answer
this question oh well to answer that question i
think you actually need these four reports and i
think we can automate all of that into one shiny
application so i think instead of giving you this
report that you then go spend 40 hours of work
to update we're going to give you a url that
solves your problem forever and we would never
have known that if we didn't have these business
relationships so to directly answer rachel what
you asked is through those relationships and
through that understanding of what the business
needs and the communication with the business we
have a platform where it's completely transparent
where we say based on what we know from each other
here's what we're doing and if there's a problem
there we're going to talk about that and we all
get to say that's not what we should be doing
or that is so it's collaborative in that effect
awesome thanks paul yeah just then sent a
note to our team to clip that i love that um
or mubanga apologies if i mispronounce your
name i see you asked a question earlier on
what is that 20 that gives you the 80 bang
in your day-to-day role would you want to
jump in and add any other context there yeah
i just wanted to find out like because what um
the teams are talking about is quite interesting
data services so i wanted to understand like uh
like the 80 20 rule like obviously there's the 20
that gives them the edge in the 80 percent of the
output so i wanted to understand that aspect of
of what they're doing basically the high level
um i guess the two things that come to mind there
are um well there's there's the boring stuff
there's the there's the data infrastructure and
pipelines and access to build tools that we think
a lot about and that we don't we don't have in a
place that we that we're happy with today but that
we're that we're moving to and and as we excuse
me as we sort of make progress you know that's
that's the amount of effort that just really
takes off like it really drives what you can do
with your analytics whenever it's not hard to
get to get to your data and then i think the
other sort of big driver of impact you know less
effort bigger impact is the communication with
business that i just talked about with the
last question um you know i'm probably just
meeting the same drum that a lot of folks
have i know there's been a lot of talk about
well actually i guess the talk is really
good about communicating results and
that's very important um but i guess really what
i'm talking about is communicating what you're
doing and why and what the business thinks about
that and getting on the same page with that is
massively successful because it just opens up
well i mean it makes everyone happier like the
people feel like they have a say they know why
they're doing what they're doing they know the
business impact of what they're doing you're
solving root problems instead of solving tickets
or higher level problems that aren't really
getting to the need of the matter and it's a
relatively low effort for the output that you get
you know talk to talk to people be people first
understand the needs i think that's key and
also maybe uh just a quick note uh developing
a high level strategy uh or some framework like
north star metric right where you have this
and then you have lagging indicator leading
indicators and then how you structure the
overall and bring to the absolute we're big on
those indicators we're big on uh performance
metrics uh from the business um okrs we're
implementing okrs to try to understand how
we're tracking our key results and goals yes all
of this is that strategy is also really important
thank you elias see you have a follow-up
question on the implementation strategy
would you want to ask that one yeah thank you
rachel um hey paul so i did have a follow-up
question about um implementation and trying to get
buy-in from teams that might be a little hesitant
um and some pointers around that for teams that
are hesitant they might be like related adopters
related adapters to like the new analytic tools
and technology so if you have any pointers around
getting over that hump yeah um i what i've done in
the past is try to show small wins that are very
directed to those individuals right so if you
if you can figure out that there's a thorn in
someone's side that's going to be a three-hour
shiny app that takes that problem away forever
even if that's not a business priority if it
doesn't connect to a kpi just do it and give
it to them and they're going to be like whoa you
can you can do that okay because i think there's
hearing and then they're seen and so i think being
able to solve small personal problems for someone
even if it's not a huge you know you can do some
stuff in r that's not exactly data science but
it might just be automation of some manual work
that takes up a huge swath of someone's time
when you show you're interested in solving
their problems they tend to come along
for for the rest of the strategy that's that's
that's the technique that i've used in the past
thank you paul yeah um tony i see you asked a
question about plumber would you want to ask that
one live sure it wasn't really about plumber what
i wanted to know was you talked about integrating
power bi into your process and i actually recently
just last week someone approached me about that
and i don't know much about power bi so i
was wondering if you could talk about the
integration of those two tools i gave an example
of my question of are you going to serve data from
plumber for power bi to consume but that's just
a guess because i don't know anything about it
right so i haven't used plumber um i think i've
used it in one project so not using it too much
i do use pins a lot to write data frames back to
rstudio connect but that mostly just serves um r
and python users um one thing i mentioned etl in
our markdown i mentioned living in our markdown
one of the great things about that is i can have
a script that uses sql queries a bunch of stuff um
brings it in uses python and r to munch it and
then uses like odbc packages to push it back into
a data science table that can then be consumed
by power bi or by our users so that's kind of the
way that we're sharing data currently um trying to
build what we're calling sort of enterprise-ready
data sources one source of truth like if you look
at your data needs you could probably bucket them
down into x buckets and you can try to build
something at the base level that works for
everyone from those buckets and then that becomes
like the source of truth for those data sources
and then you can write them in such a way where
power bi or shiny or dash or whatever users can
can access that that data now when i think
about the future where i have power bi fully
automated and i have um shiny applications and
i have like uh model outputs and stuff like that
yeah i would probably use something like a plumber
api to make sure that everyone could grab those to
integrate into their apps that'd probably be
one solution we just haven't gotten there yet
okay thanks i mean it sounds like you're pushing
to a database so that way those tools can use
their built-in database connectivity to get you
you got it whenever my powerball user opens and
sees connections i want them to have that you know
it might be a table that came from our process but
to them it's going to be just a source they can
use to build what they need right yeah okay thanks
thanks paul um i see a few people sent
in questions and said they're in a busy
office right now so i'll read them
but one was how often do you revisit
a model that's already in production do you
have any fixed cycle or depending on need
so um when i build something like that i always
build some some sort of flex dashboard or shiny
application that monitors performance for that
model something i can quickly go to and look at
and see what's going on and i i'm kind of
that nerd that likes to go look at that
a lot so i tend to just naturally you know
during my morning coffee look and see what's
going on i i don't really have like a schedule or
anything of course if i hear a problem from a user
like i feel like uh there's something wrong here
i i go i go look at it then but um so yeah i think
that's the answer thank you and then one just
clarification question they asked um not sure
if this was already discussed but how do you host
your shiny apps to the business users oh yeah we
use we use RStudio team so we have RStudio connect
on prem so we also have RStudio um workbench
so a lot of development in workbench where we have
all of our handy-dandy connections and protocols
sort of set up so you can pretty quickly bang on
a shiny app hit the hit the blue publish button
push it to connect and then you can pull it up
you can quickly set a vanity url set um who can
see it who can't and then we share that we are
working on what our solution is going to be but
we really really we really don't want every user
to come land on connect to like find their app
but there's some really cool ways like you can you
can use blog down for example to build something
custom there's a new package to come out it's not
the connect api package it's called something else
that lets you pretty quickly build a landing page
on connect that that is a sort of one-stop shop
for your content we also use um echo internally so
we've toured with building a data science landing
page for those tools but so anyway if they're
sort of sharing with the user which is easy
you should just send them a link but then there's
like how do you let people come sort of find and
that we're still toying with but it's probably
going to be some sort of r developed connect
hosted website that lets people come and
explore the data science products that are there
great thank you um there's a question from
earlier sorry i was just scrolling up to find
um was any management any management or
leadership principles that you could share
management or leadership principles well you know
i mentioned earlier being people focused i think
that's really important i think especially
in current day with pandemic supply chains
child care um people losing people to covid you
really you really have to remember that we're
all people first we're people that are coming
to work so i i try to remember that every day
i think you also have to i think you have to have
a culture of it's okay to fail actually it's good
to fail um fail fast fail often uh get get to the
thing that that works meet people where they are
um give give them the tools they need to grow
find out what they care about and like and
try to give them more of that um celebrate
success and learn from failure um so yeah i
don't know i guess that's my laminated card
of like bullet point leadership quotes yeah
thank you i see shannon you had a follow-up
question there if you want to just ask that too
yeah sure i was just curious if your
management and leadership came naturally
to you or if that was something you worked
towards through mentorship or reading books
oh um well i i've always been sort of a people
person of course that doesn't mean you're a
good leader or a good manager managing is such
a is such a different thing and uh to directly
answer your question when i went from what
was called an in an individual contributor
to a people leader at my previous job thankfully i
was in a i was in an organization that recognized
the difference there if if you're a person who
is a especially if you're a person who really
cares about your work you're a go-getter you're
typing code all the time you're giving products
you're solving problems you're seeing the fruits
of your labor directly when you hand someone a
link and you're like and they're like oh my god
i can do this great thing now that i couldn't do
before thank you so much when you go from that
to now your job is to manage these x people
and provide them with success and clear the path
for them and make them rock stars it is a it's
being thrown into the deep end of the swimming
pool and you're no longer getting that personal
feedback that you used to get from solving
problems yourself so i was lucky enough to have
i mean i think it was about
six months of different hr led
trainings and seminars and resources given to
me to understand that change and understand um
really you're not you don't just have your lever
now you have a you have a lever for the team
and you and you have more impact but it's in a
different way and the thing that's important to
your day-to-day completely changes and i think i
would have struggled with that a lot longer than
i did i mean i did struggle with it even with even
with the help but i think i would have struggled
with it even longer had i not been given those
resources so i mean that's probably an important
note that as you if you're a person who is a
data scientist and you see yourself becoming a
leader one day um just just keep that in mind that
it's gonna be a change it's going to feel weird
it's going to be a shift and honestly not everyone
likes that like i've worked with people who got a
taste of that and decided they'd rather be a data
science based technical leader that's what they
wanted to do instead of being a more people leader
it really depends on what you like but i do think
that you you can learn with resources of course
to to be better at it just just like anything
thanks paul um tony i'm not gonna try and
summarize your question i'm just going to
call on you to ask that one fine i don't want to
like dominate the discussion but i heard paul say
something which triggered a um a thought from we
you talked about using the pins package a lot and
i've seen RStudio kind of push that package and
it looks real real nice and this is all great
but our problem with it is that then we're storing
data in connect and i don't believe we at least we
don't believe right now connect is hardened
enough for things like our crown jewel data
it's not a dial chemical so there's quite a bit of
variety of data that we deal with right and some
data businesses consider crown jewels so they
don't want they want to know exactly who and
how is accessing that data and so we have not
i would say validated connect as a means of a
data repository so we use it to host things
that reach out to a database and then we can
use things like run as user to ensure the
connection and you know we're passing our
you know cabros credentials to the database so we
know who is the person who access that data so how
do you guys deal with more sensitive data in in
connect and do you have a kind of a policy around
what data you can pin and whether you can't and
how do you how do you like deal with that right
and you know if RStudio wants to jump in you know
anyone there and tell me how they'll make pins
more um secure and i'm not saying it's not
secure it's just like access to it is kind of
you know i control it right so anyway if you could
talk about pins and how you guys are using that
um yeah so if i guess i'm being completely honest
you know we're we're working on our overall data
strategy as a part of this transition going from
the traditional um tools and techniques that we're
using into the new tools and techniques that
we're using um currently pins are great because
you can sort of work within rstudio workbench and
you can build an end-to-end etl app collaborative
pipeline and push those things and host them
and have them all work without really needing to
uh pull resources from from somewhere else
i get your point about data security um i
mean i know that you can just like any
other object in connect you can control
if it's open access if it's by group like we
use ada active directory for our our studio
connect instance so we can control by individual
or by group who can see any object like including
pins now of course you know it admin will be
able to see that kind of like anything else
sorry i just heard something um upstairs i'm not
sure what that is anyway maybe someone's at my
door um so you know we have our traditional
data warehouse that we're using to save
and store and work off most of our you're calling
crown jewel data sources a lot of the stuff we
have in pins right now are sort of intermediate
steps to get us to an application or get us to
a model i don't know what the future looks like
for um for pins data storage long term i mean i
doubt that's going to be like our data warehouse
though that's kind of not that's not what it
is in my mind and then i guess our studio can
jump in if they have another thought about that
i of course can't speak to it as well as our
engineers would be able to but i'm wondering if
you could use environment variables with pins
as well to make that more secure but i'm just
going to share a helpful link on pins too i think
that's not the real issue the real issue is you
have to have a policy around what data can and
can't go there sure so i think our decision was
we just don't put data into connect you know as
like a policy right which then we don't use pins
and we try to find you know a different approach
for it and i didn't know if you guys had that
policy defined like this is you know please don't
put you know detailed schematics of unknown to the
world reactors into pins not saying you can i'm
just an example right please don't put like the
newest billion dollar catalyst molecule structure
into pins right so we don't have that right and so
it's kind of it's kind of hard to define that so
that's why i was wondering have you defined any
policy around it or right now it's kind of a free
brawl for data science and you'll deal with that
you know later yeah that's it's it's definitely
the latter like i i understand what you're saying
and we we um our security team is very um worried
a lot about everything security based so whenever
we brought our studio team in and we talked about
connect and who has access and what's being stored
there we had a lot of conversations about what
we were doing um so i guess there's sort of an
unspoken rule of certain things aren't going on
connect we don't have a policy but again it's
it's something that we know we need and we want
to have but we just we just haven't got to yet
i think we're all in the same boat then yeah
yeah one of those things lots of conversations
right that's right
i'm scrolling through to see if there's any
questions i miss so feel free to jump in
if you have anything that you want to ask um one
question i will ask you paul because i'm trying to
figure out how to create a resource for this but
i've i've talked to a lot of people who are in
like the very early stages of kind of like being
our champion and maybe making some presentation
for their architecture review design board
or whatever internal review process they have
and i am just wondering how you actually went
about doing that whether at your last role or
or now to get our studio approved um right so i
i started off like i mentioned earlier by doing
things with free open source versions locally so
first it was like hey can i get rstudio it's open
source you know here's what it does it's an ide
and that's usually short you can do that and then
can i download you know packages approved packages
on crayon and that's usually not a problem either
at least it wasn't for me um and then once
you have that i mean you you basically had
everything right now you can install our markdown
shiny you can you can you can pull in local data
you can show a shiny application running locally
you can do like i mentioned earlier and make a
flex dashboard and send that out as an html file
to people so they can see what that looks like
and then you can um build a strategy i remember
making slide decks i think i've shown some of
these slide decks art studio actually where i was
like basically said hey here's how you do things
now you know here's the current state diagram
of how you do analytics how people consume them
and here's what you could do if we had some
set of data science tools and then i would show
literal examples of that and then i would say and
here's what that would look like to acquire and so
that's how i convinced people to to give me
those tools so that i could do better work
thank you that's that's really helpful so it's
like actual slide deck presentation that you
brought to yep nr yeah i did it nr like knitted
it to pdf and i would even say like you know
the slide deck was made in r like there's lots of
i remember a presentation i gave on our markdown
they just talked about just the incredible you
know swiss army knife capabilities of it and sort
of what it could do stuff it could replace ways we
could use it instead of other things that we use
now um so communicating value and then
using i i think one time i called it like a
stair-step approach right like if you can get
rstudio or r and get access to cram packages
on your work machine and use local data sources
well then you can sort of stair step that out
you know you can find a you can find a business
need that someone needs to be solved and you can
solve it better right like someone needs an
analysis like i remember when i was it when
i was at bf like someone at someone had this
data that was coming out of like um an hplc
which is which is a chemical analysis where you
put liquid in this machine and then you get this
output of all the chemistry that's there right and
they're like hey we need to understand descriptive
statistics for these chemical compounds and
we need like an ovarian and we need this this
and the second time she asked me i just built
a shiny app and i and i actually gave the local
code just on her machine and i was like the next
time you do this you know press this run button
and then it looks like a web page upload your
file and everything you just asked me to do will
just be done and then that person was like holy
crap that's amazing and then they talked about
it to everybody and then next thing you know you
have individuals coming to you saying oh you know
and then that gets the attention of leadership as
well and so that's you know you can sort of work
at that ground level as well solve problems for
individuals like i mentioned earlier then while
you're doing that that becomes part of the example
that you lay out in your presentation of like
look this is why hey we can do this b i have been
doing it see here's the feedback from that and d
here's the solution to make this you know a real
thing we're doing instead of a thing that i'm like
covertly doing on my laptop but you may have to
break a few a few rules now i'm not telling you
to like disregard your policies or whatever but
if i'm being honest like i probably did a couple
of things that certain people in it didn't really
like and but i'm the kind of person that i think
you break a few windows because you know the new
house is going to be awesome and that's just the
way that it is and so that's what i did and it is
more awesome now so i'm okay with that decision
that's awesome thank you paul sorry i'm like i'm
beating this question but i'm just really trying
to understand how i give people advice for this
when they ask me how other people do it but that
presentation that you give was that to leadership
or was it in that from the beginning as well or
so at the time at the time that i did that
this was in my previous role because i kind
of came in at this level here so i didn't have to
worry about it uh but then it was it was to um my
immediate management who who took that up
which eventually became an i.t conversation
because when you start asking which got me
connected to i.t because you know depending
on where you work in your organization
you might not have a connection to i.t
so that's another thing that you need to that
you need to get so i would even recommend like
it might be hard in today's environment too with
remote working but if you can try to uh you know
set up some lunches with folks you don't
know in it reach out to those folks
talk about analytics try to meet people who work
on those teams building those connections is also
helpful for that but from what i did it was
immediate management which went up that chain
which eventually got to this point where hey we
want to do this and they were told cool talk to
it and then it kind of became this collaborative
discussion about about getting it implemented
and i even faced questions like we were using
tableau at the time and you know i got asked like
why do we need this we have to have low and so i
put together a whole another thing about how well
you have these analysts professionals the temple
is awesome for them but then you have data science
and here's like a table of what each thing is
good and not good at and why you really need both
of them to solve this problem and that was like
the final thing i did that got the check signed
thank you so much there's actually a question
about around tableau as well someone just asked
how do you think about when and why you'd want to
use something like power bi or tableau versus when
you'd use shiny or our markdown yeah so honestly
i am now you know i i'm incredibly biased like
we all are um i i prefer code based solutions for
lots of reasons i think they're much more flexible
i think you can integrate all of the awesome
things that are in that ecosystem right so in
shiny any r package any r function all the custom
functions i've written in my custom packages any
new model any new statistical method or theory
that comes out is going to be in our right i
mean that's that's what the programming language
sort of is for and then i can immediately use that
stuff in anything that i make it's all code based
i can collaborate with code i can do things like
pull requests i can do things like have a git repo
i can do things like have it be transparent have
to be reproducible have it be completely re you
know you can make it again with a button press you
can compile it all over again because again it's
code based i think that those benefits are just
they're hard to match with a gooby based
system just because it is a gui based system
now where i think tools like that are helpful
is not everyone's a coder not everyone's a data
scientist there are lots of very smart capable
analysts who know their business know what the
business needs but they don't know are and
they need something again to get to that
modern web-based output single-click consumption
model without needing to write code and so that's
why in my mind it's a parallel service diagram
of two different paths for those type of folks
and for data science types of folks but there
are also lines going between them right i want
those models to be used in the tableau workbook in
the power bi workbook there's collaboration there
there's the same sort of data infrastructure
we're working off of but there's two different
parallel paths for that reason but if i
had my druthers though like if i say i
was starting my own company i would absolutely
be biased toward let's do everything with code
thank you paul and i know we're getting to
the top of the hour but there's a few more
questions if that's okay sure yeah okay um one
was recommendations for someone to transition
into data science um so they said they've taken
r python training but they don't use it in their
current role how do you get better at coding
i highly recommend literally working through
r for data science from cover to cover if you if
you can work through that book and you understand
everything in that book you're ready for uh
in my opinion for an entry level job in data
science if you can show that you like if a new
candidate came to me and they um had a github repo
with some projects they worked on for fun like i
remember when flex dashboard first came out like
you know 84 years ago and i wanted to learn it and
i just had some i knew that census data had like
or there was a package for like baby names and i
was like and i was having a child and i was like
what if i made some shiny app using flex dashboard
to understand trends about baby names and so
that's how i learned so i did that and i had
it in github and every project i did i tried
to keep there so eventually you have this really
cool portfolio so even if you're not doing it in
your job you have work that you can show someone
who's hiring you that um you are interested in it
and that you know what you're doing and really
like i think that's all that matters at the end
of the day can you show competency um in that area
and i think that having that passion of like i'm
gonna learn this i'm gonna build something cool on
the weekends or in the evening also shows me that
you're kind of the person i want to hire because
i like passionate people who love what they do and
clearly you are because you've got this cool
github repo of all the packages that you like
thank you i think that actually kind of answers
this next question as well but was um in terms
of hiring what makes data science data science
candidates stand out or how do you hire for your
team yeah yeah i i'm pretty um i'm open like a
brown formula we had a python arm make so we all
collaborated it's great i'm open to that now too
but i think showing me competency and data science
um again i'm biased toward our you know we use
RStudio Team as our sort of data science platform
showing me that that you are comfortable in our
markdown you know tidy verse um showing me code
showing you projects you've done in github there's
also this piece though that i feel can be lacking
i think that data science is so popular and it
has blown up so much that some i have run into
people who are really good at that but they
really don't have a sound statistical theory
and i don't think there's a substitute for having
just a basic understanding of of statistics like
what is this regression model thing that you're
doing what assumptions does it have why does it
work like what's the central limit theorem um how
would you guide someone if they had a data set and
they didn't know how to analyze it and i think
you'd have to have that other background so i
think that's something for folks to keep in mind
if they don't come from like a stats background
that that's something they should at least think
about doing not it's not just the r and the python
and the packages it's also knowing the stats
and how to use them and how to communicate them
to the business that's also huge like like
one day like if you use logistic regression
one day think about how would you explain to
like the vp of marketing what an odds ratio is
like honestly think about that
it's it's not it's not intuitive
right like try to get good at doing stuff
like that and you'll be very very valuable
that's great thank you so much paul yeah i should
have asked this earlier but is there a question
that you'd like to ask to the audience as
well on the spot no i don't think i have
one no i was so worried about um being good at
answering questions that i didn't think of one
i should say that next time but um
i i don't think there's any other questions i
do would just want to take a second to pause to
make sure if i missed anything that feel
free to unmute yourself and and speak up
but one question we always like to ask at the
end paul is if people want to get in touch
with you what's the best way is it linkedin or
twitter yeah i would say find me on linkedin
you can connect with me there and you
can direct message me there as well
frank i see you unmuted i take that as you raising
your hand uh i was just gonna throw in there um
paul when are we getting our free samples do you
need our addresses uh yeah wouldn't that be great
i'll have to check with marketing sales see if
i'm allowed i think there are also some laws
around shipping alcohol i'm not really sure but
you know whenever you're at target next you can
probably pick up some evan williams or elijah
craig there if you're in one that sells liquor
okay well we all get together sometime
in in person maybe at RStudio conference
we can have a nice little uh whiskey tasting there
yeah maybe we can get a heaven hill sponsorship
for the for the drinks i'll see what i can do
well thank you so much paul i really appreciate
your time and and sharing all your insights
with us and thank you all for joining too
hopefully see you all next week same time
same place have a great rest of the day
you